[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in steve padozzolo our good
buddy from pro football focus senior
analyst there host of the pro football
focus nfl podcast
what is baker mayfield worth right now
based off of
what happened this past season
yeah it's a tough one because i think
you know baker mayfield his evaluation
just doesn't make sense you know like
every time it looks like he should get
better they bring in obj he didn't
really get better then obj gets goes
down and he has an excellent finish to
his 2020 season and then last year
baker's playing hurt and i don't you
know it affected him it absolutely
affected him playing even though it's
his non-throwing shoulder playing
through injury it was the worst even
we've seen of baker mayfield and i do
think between that and how outspoken
he's been without necessarily backing it
up from a production standpoint i think
nfl teams have stowed on him so um i
think his value's down right now but uh
he's also a guy that i would still want
to take a shot on just because two out
of his four seasons his rookie year and
then 2020 overall he's looked really
good in those in those particular
seasons but is he worth the number one
draft uh a first round draft pick
two first-round picks
all the leverage is gone now because
people know he's on the block right i
mean he's not sticking around with
deshawn watson there in cleveland so
it's probably a mid-round pick at best
and there's we're running out of
desperate teams as far as the
quarterback carousel goes
what about jimmy garoppolo what's his
value
yeah i mean jimmy's another tough one
right because he wins a ton of games and
then you go back and you say okay he's
been in kyle shanahan's system and
our grades i think do a pretty good job
of kind of separating garoppolo's
performance from what the offense has
done it's always been one of the most
productive passing games in the in the
nfl when garoppolo's been under center
but his last two full seasons he's our
13th ranked quarterback in 2019 when
they went to the super bowl number 21
last year but the stats are really good
so i do think
you know garoppolo's value's probably a
little bit higher you can have one more
year of his contract but you also have
to try to separate his production
from shanahan's system where garoppolo's
grades don't necessarily match up you
know with the staff so he's a guy that
you probably have to have a really good
situation around him much like he had in
san francisco but i could see teams
looking at garoppolo a little bit
you know higher than baker at this point
you know maybe it ends up becoming a
second or third round pick
i know you grade rosters so here we are
we're done with free agency for the most
part um
which team improved their roster the
most in your opinion
yeah i mean it's such a quarterback
driven league that it is the teams that
added the big-time quarterbacks right i
mean the denver broncos adding russell
wilton that wasn't all they did though
obviously having randy gregory come in
and resigning a couple of their own and
the broncos overall have made some
excellent moves but of course going from
teddy bridgewater to russell wilson
absolutely elevates their feeling uh the
indianapolis colt even just uh in aging
matt ryan has still played pretty good
ball over the last couple of years and
you put him on a roster that probably
should have been in the playoffs last
year in indianapolis i think ryan's
going to play better than carson wentz
has a chance to elevate the colts there
and of course the browns you know even
though
outside of amari cooper they haven't
made a ton of other big splash moves or
anything but the browns already had a
really good roster and you're going from
baker mayfield's worst season to
presumably
whatever deshawn watson brings to the
table which would be much better
you start to look at these teams that
gave up their quarterbacks like the the
falcons
uh that's a bad team um
are they
one of the worst rosters bottom three
four teams in the nfl
yeah i think they are i mean over the
last couple of years we've seen their
odd their defense essentially get
depleted that they have uh they have
brady jarrett they have aj terrell but
not much else dion jones is pretty good
not much to build on the defensive side
and then offensively everything's
falling apart there as well where they
have maybe the worst receiving core in
the league and they're just a couple of
years removed from having julio jones
and calvin ridley and russell gage over
there so
um it's a complete rebuild in atlanta
which might not be the worst thing right
you've got tom brady in the division the
falcons you know second year coach and
gm it might be time for the falcons
anyway to start looking to 2023 2024 uh
for whenever tom brady moves on and
think about competing in a couple years
rather than this year
all right we have a bet here in studio
that uh there will be a quarterback
selected the first 13 picks
which side of the bet are you on
oh i definitely think there will be yeah
i mean you're looking at the panthers at
six
the falcons at eight and then the
seahawks at nine you know in this
musical chairs of quarterback movement
they're they're left without a chair at
the moment and yeah garoppolo is out
there yeah baker mayfield's out there
but i do think
the panthers have been desperate the
falcons as i mentioned they're in the
middle of this rebuilds they probably
want to find a guy in the seahawks right
i mean i don't think they're going to
hitch their wagons into through block i
think they're going to evaluate this
class so i think because of that
we are talking about quarterbacks going
probably in the top 10 at least one or
two
um even though
i don't think the nfl loves this
quarterback class overall and do you
think desperation will win and somebody
will go in the top 10 or so
great to talk to you as always steve
we'll stay in touch thanks for joining
us
yeah always a pleasure that's steve
palazzolo pro football focus senior
analyst there and uh pro football focus
launching a four episode podcast series
this april with the projected number one
overall pick aiden hutchinson subscribe
to hutch wherever you listen to podcasts
there